this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 38 Echo Charles sitting here with
me Echo Charles yes sir I'm gonna use
your
your situation let's say to sort of
frame up a conversation possibly maybe
we get right through it maybe we don't
maybe just the topic but
thinking of reputation you know the
reputation in this hill team is very
important
I I have fun with your reputation you
know meaning I kind of have presented a
reputation for you against your will in
some cases of this level of cruising and
relaxing and maybe not super overly
concerned about work or anything like
that
first of all
has that ever bothered you
no no okay second of all
if it did bother you
how would you handle it and I'm gonna
answer that right now
if it bothered you the way to handle it
would be the way you're handling it
right now okay so even if it bothered
you right now secretly and you were like
no it doesn't bother me that's the way
to handle it so this is my advice right
keep it up yeah if if something if
someone's
you know harassing you about something
or you're they're they're doing
something saying something and you don't
like it the worst thing you could do is
let everyone know that you don't like it
this is like lesson day one of the same
teams because if you show that something
bothers you you're gonna that's gonna
stick if you don't let it show that then
people will move on because it gets
boring yeah if I started if I was making
fun of you all the time actually the
only reason I keep teasing you about
this stuff is because it's funny you
laugh I laugh we have you know we're fun
it's funny
if you weren't laughing and I was just
oh then I probably would have moved on
to something else to try and harass you
out and front try and find them some
little
some little [__] in the armor to get
through
so reputations
um
if someone is in a situation where their
reputation isn't what they want it to be
how do you course correct that
I'm gonna say first of all
you gotta kind of own it meaning hey the
reason I have this reputation is
something that I'm doing is earning me
this reputation yeah
a lot of times people think that you
know everyone just says that about me
they're against me they're trying to
make me look bad and what is this this
is the opposite of extreme ownership
we're blaming other people which means
you're not going to make any adjustments
to whatever it is you're doing that's
earning you this reputation in the first
place
so your reputation didn't appear out of
thin air your reputation actually came
from something that you did
unintentional intentional knowing
unknowing but you did something that
that made people focus on this aspect of
you and that little aspect is now turned
into a reputation
If you deny it let's do it that's not me
no that's not the right move
we have to actually take ownership of
the reputation that we got and if
there's adjustments that need to be made
to it we need to adjust our behavior in
order to adjust our reputation
reputation is strategic
meaning it's a long-term item it's you
do you can do things tactically
that can help your reputation that can
hurt your reputation but over time you
have to maintain the long term
the long game on reputation you can't
you can't be
a slacker a slacker a slacker work hard
one day and think your reputation is
gonna be good yeah
you can't be
um Angry temper emotional and then one
day try not calm and you think your
reputation doesn't work like that it
doesn't work like that it's reputation
is a strategic thing that you need to
think about
and you need to act strategic when it
comes to how you carry yourself and how
it's going to impact your reputation
that's the way it works
so
if you notice or you start to you start
to feel like your reputation is not
where you want it to be
assess Own It assess what Corrections
you need to make by the way
I don't recommend
radical changes
where you know I've been lazy I've been
lazy I've been lazy and one day I just
come in and start working Ultra hard
because people don't
I'm not saying you can't do that
but it's going everyone's gonna kind of
feel that everyone's going to kind of be
like oh it doesn't seem like a lasting
thing it's not it's a tactical move but
not a strategic move it's a tax remove
it's not a strategic move
if you say oh hey let me pick up that
other shift
continually
you know let me take this let me take
that extra shift for the Long Haul oh
you got that little project I can take
that thing you want to go and say I got
the new shift I got this I got that no
it's too much people don't buy don't
people don't believe it it's like a fad
diet yeah okay right hey hey I I'm only
I'm I'm going on the carnivore diet
right I'm a carnivore now I'm a
carnivore now it's like dude
you you just got done with a freaking
you know ice cream cake
No One Believes you
No One Believes you a whole ice cream a
whole ice cream did you have ice cream
cakes growing up oh what size is that
like an Oreo cookie ice cream cake does
it count I I don't know but when I was a
kid it was a thing yeah yeah you could
go to a I think we got them from Carvel
have you ever heard of Carvel it was an
ice cream kind of store because you
could get an ice cream cake which is
basically a which is basically the thing
in the shape of an ice cream
um the thing in the shape of a cake
but it's ice cream and there's some kind
of crust scenario happening you know
what yes so here here's the thing this
is gonna side note but it's important I
think for us so two things first off
when I had covid
I ate an ice cream cake a Reese's I
think it was like a peanut butter ice
cream yeah that's what I thought but you
couldn't taste your smell I couldn't
this is before I knew I had covet by the
way it was for Thanksgiving so I'm
eating it I'm like this is very under
freaking like whelming underwhelming
cake this under delivered this is not a
good ice cream cake from what it looks
like right because it didn't taste good
it tastes sweet but that was it that
couldn't taste the peanut butter you
know what I've come to expect and so
whatever so that's how I remember okay
ice cream cake that's an ice cream cake
but when I think about it there's yeah
there's there's okay so there's a place
on Kauai Called keoki's Paradise I
recommend anyone who goes straight up go
to keoki's South Side by the ice cream
shop nope dinner place oh dinner nice
dinner place they got live music and
stuff sometimes like the Hawaiian music
stuff really good really good spot this
is what my wife does actually I
shouldn't tell I shouldn't tell this
secret but this is what she does when we
plan a trip let's say it's like a few
months in advance she'll call keoki's
and make a reservation for every night
us being there
that way you're guaranteed to have a
reservation and then if we plan not to
go she'll call and cancel it on the day
of her day before how hard is it to get
a reservation there well right now it's
very hard okay so yeah you kind of can't
if you're like you're on quiet let's go
tomorrow or whatever you can't really
get one anymore either way side note so
they're one of their desserts that you
can get is called a hula pie
and it's an ice cream cake okay and it's
like this High yeah it's like it means
one foot tall people that are just
listening it's very hot yes and then you
could tell it's part of a big huge cake
that you get one slice but it's for the
whole table it's not a one person gig
depending on who you are yes sir you're
correct you're right but it uh that is a
good good ice cream cake it's called
hula pie Okay so
apparently it is so one minute I'm
eating a hula pot like legit think about
this you and me we're in Hawaii every
day we're going to kill every day we're
going to kill because I'm getting
a uh hula pie on The Daily yes sir and
then one day I wake up and I go hey I'm
a carnivore
what is your level of belief in my
scenario okay believe it when I see it
kind of it's not hot yeah in fact it's
kind of it's almost disrespectful for me
to even say that to you yeah it's almost
like I'm just a liar yes right yeah it's
almost like this is just not believable
yeah so we have to think about that same
thing so it ends up being important the
hula pie ends up being important because
if we're eating hula pies and then all
of a sudden we're saying what carnivore
doesn't work if we are lazy and all of a
sudden we're trying to act like we're
the hard worker is not going to work
either it's not going to work overnight
now look if I tell you I'm a carnivore
and then you know we go out for dinner
that night and you're like hey you're
gonna get the hula pie and I go no man
I'm gonna get chicken wings yeah because
you know because I'm a carnivore now and
you go okay
you might have a little bit more belief
but it's not going to change you
overnight yeah so same thing with your
reputation your reputation is not gonna
change overnight it's going to take time
it's going to take effort it's gonna
take strategic thinking you're gonna
have to you're gonna also have to think
about what you do tactically this is you
you hear me talk about how a tactical
mistake can have a strategic impact
right so Abu garib prison these guys and
girls these men and women I guess
they're not kids but these men and women
that
put these put these uh insurgents and
terrorists and suspected terrorists into
these body positions and took pictures
and all the stuff that they did with
them all that stuff that they did with
them in Abu grave
look
that's a tactical situation they're in a
prison it's not it's not a strategic
move to do that they weren't they
weren't trying to say win the war with
these by stacking these guys and
stripping them naked and putting a dog
leash that wasn't good that wasn't a
strategic move
but it had a strategic impact a negative
strategic impact
so it's the same thing with our
reputation
if you make dumb tactical moves
that might not seem like a big deal to
you you might kind of shrug your
shoulders and say whatever oh it doesn't
matter if I just cut this corner right
now but if
that little corner that you cut some
people you know what's a big one like
dishonesty right if you're dishonest
about something that you don't really
think is a big deal yeah you know you're
supposed to
do some that what am I one of my
daughters had the opportunity to lie to
me my youngest daughter had the
opportunity to lie to me the other day
uh what did I say to her
anyways I looked at her she just said I
didn't do that or whatever like she was
supposed to do something and I asked her
if she did it and she's she just looked
at me and just said no I didn't do it
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground